[Music]
or more of the things that we find
valuable way less and less more and more
other value is in the things that don't
have any weight or mass these
intangibles are really what becomes the
driver of our economy and if we can
deliver these intangibles anytime
anywhere to anybody
that instant aspect of them means that
we in fact don't have to own them
anymore
so I really don't any movies I subscribe
to Netflix I don't really own much music
I have Spotify or Pandora Apple music
and I'm increasingly that's going to be
true for games and books and if it's
true for all those things that we can
make intangible very easily it also is
true that the benefits of subscribing to
something rather than owning them or
moving to the physical world as well and
we can see something like uber as an
example of that where if you can summon
a car anytime anywhere you want to why
would you own it it's going to be as
good and maybe even better than owning
because ownership has a lot of
liabilities storing cleaning maintaining
upgrading that we actually don't really
want to have if we can subscribe and not
own a car but have all the benefits of
using a car what about other things
how far can it go we can kind of imagine
pushing this to some far logical extreme
where maybe some individual in the
future doesn't really own very much of
anything they can access or subscribe to
everything in their lives maybe we can
put all these together in kind of an
extreme form and imagine a day in your
life as somebody who is going about
without owning any of the things that we
normally associate with owning maybe
even like clothes so the way that would
go is if you could have instant delivery
to your box someone
they're within a few hours of anything
you need to anywhere you were in the
world
maybe you subscribe to clothes and
clothes come to you you wear them once
they're taken away they're recycled and
clean and they're given to someone else
who may only wear them once and with
clothes this is already happening in the
high-end of tuxedos and things that we
know we don't eat where occasionally but
you can even go into daily wear as well
if again it was something that was being
recycled and cleaned and sent on to
someone else who body was scanned and
digitized and we knew from experience
that these clothes were going to fit
their body basically and you could have
digital avatars where you could try
clothes on if we can imagine clothes
why not furniture why not toys toys are
used for a short time by kids as they
grow up and maybe they could be
subscribed to instead of being purchased
what about tools kitchen stuff that you
only use occasionally the turkey roaster
that you could summon on Thanksgiving
have delivered to your house within an
hour you use give it back they clean it
they store it and they'll be ready to
deliver to you whenever you need it
again camping equipment
everybody wants the latest and the
greatest high tech this year's most
sophisticated camping technology why
would you buy camping equipment when you
only use it occasionally you could
subscribe to the best instead so we can
kind of multiply this again and again to
the vision we're removing from ownership
to access if you can get access to
things instant delivery maybe even 3d
printing things given and manufactured
and put in front of you on demand then
that in many ways for most people
becomes better than owning it
[Music]